(rock music)
- Montana is a landlocked state.
It blows my mind everyday,
but there is waves in the river
and you can surf 'em on surfboards
just like you would in the ocean.
We have a huge surf
culture here in Missoula.
(rock music)
My name's Kevin Benhardt Brown, I go by KB,
and I own Strongwater
Mountain Surf Company.
(tools blaring)
We are the original mountain surf shop
and still the only surf shop
in the state of Montana.
I mean, it's cowboy country here.
Surfing is in my soul,
one of my very first, earliest
memories at the age of three
is visiting my grandparents in San Diego
and seeing surfing in the ocean.
And for whatever reason
I've been kind of searching
for surfing my whole life
and I happen to be here
in Missoula, Montana
and tapped into river surfing.
In the river, it's a standing wave,
so the wave is essentially stationary.
You're going back and
forth across the wave,
but the wave is kind of in one place,
the water's comin' at
you, it's pretty amazing.
(rock music)
You know, we've built
a really strong river surf community here.
There's just a ton of support
and good vibes, good energy.
(water splashing)
This whole connection with
nature correlates directly with
kind of that same vibe
that you get in the ocean.
Not a lot of people know
about river surfing,
but there's river surfing
communities popping up everywhere
and it's just starting to explode.
For me personally,
it's about doing what people
don't think you can do
and proving that you can do it
and you know, just getting out
and having a good time, sharing the sport.
It's exciting and fun to be
on this whole new frontier.
(electronic dinging)